- My name is Sten Vermund.
I serve as Dean of the Yale
School of Public Health.
But I wanted to just highlight
the partnership of Yale University
with the American University of Beirut.
The AUB dates back more than 150 years.
Founded.
In 1866.
And there were
American's who were literally fundraising
to start this school in Beirut
during the American Civil
War just to give you a sense.
And just after the American Civil War.
So.
The university has been
a highly stable academic force
with American accreditation.
It was originally accredited
by New York State Educational.
Entities.
And all the many years
with all the trials and
tribulations of the Middle East
AUB has maintained its
leadership role in academia.
And we're proud that
that includes medicine
and it includes public health and nursing.
So let me turn it over
to Doctor Khoshnood.
We have been proud to be
working with AUB for many years.
And we'll be hearing from its
former dean in just a moment.
Doctor Khoshnood.
- Thank you so much Stan.
Again I'm Kaveh Khoshnood
Associate Professor Yale
School of Public Health.
I've had the pleasure
of knowing doctor Iman
for over a decade.
And I'm delighted to introduce him to you.
Doctor Iman Nuwayhid is
Professor of Public Health
and Occupation at Environmental Health
at the Faculty of Health Sciences
at the American University of Beirut.
He served as the dean for 12 years
at the faculty health
sciences from 2008 to 2020.
He's co-editor of the landmark book
on "Public Health in the Arab World",
Cambridge University press 2012.
Add he's a co-chair of the
Lancet-AUB Commission on Syria.
His research focuses on
the health of workers
including working children,
environment and health,
and conflict and health.
I'm so delighted that doctor Iman
who's on sabbatical right
now decided to come to Yale,
he's currently in New Haven
and is teaching the first ever course
called Public Health in the
Arab World at Yale College.
Doctor Iman thank you
so much for joining us,
I'll turn it over to you.
- Thank you Kaveh and
thank you dean Vermund
for your kind words.
Let me start by sharing my first.
Slide here.
So before I start I'd like
to first good afternoon
to everyone who has joined.
And I want to start by thanking
the Institute of Global Health,
the School of Public Health at Yale,
and the MacMillan Center
Council on Middle East Studies
for hosting this presentation.
I want specifically to thank the council
on Middle East studies for hosting me
for this semester at Yale.
And special thanks to
Professor Marcia Inhorn
who was the force behind it.
I also would like to
like to move the slide so.
Okay.
Also like to
just recognize my 12 brilliant
undergraduate students
who took the course in
Public Health in Arab World,
I would say they were
quite an inspiration.
The term shattered
that you see in the
pilot of my presentation
actually is borrowed from this documentary
produced by director Carol
Mansour from Lebanon.
And it talks mainly about a reflections
on the Beirut explosion of
August four 2020 a year later.
And of course the shattered here
refers to the shattered windows
and doors and structures,
but also to the shattered humanity
that we all experienced at that point.
My objectives here what
I'd like to share with you
and I am putting them in a form
of an unusually for objectives,
in form of question.
Because I'm still questioning myself
and I'd like you to
join me on this thinking
of what lens should we use
to analyze public health challenges?
And proposing a more or less
a different way of looking
at time, place, and person,
and I'll explain that as we move forward.
Again, this presentation
is not going to be
about numerators and denominators
and really about prevalences.
Few numbers here and there.
It's going to be mostly focusing
on the social politic
and historical context,
actually more on the
political and historical
to just give a meaning
to why are we in the
situation that we're facing?
Not only in Lebanon and the
region, also across the globe.
What lessons can we learn to
inform global public health?
And what can we do all together
perhaps to achieve a fairer world?
I will start where you will not expect.
I am going to define my place
as Minneapolis, Minnesota.
My time as 25 May '22.
And my person, so this is the place, time,
and my person is George Floyd.
George Floyd is, was died
at the age of 46 years.
He's a black American
and he was a victim of police brutality
for different reasons,
one of them you all know
and that's this the color
of the skin that he carries.
One of his last words
what he whispered before he passed away
was "I cannot breathe".
And.
That incident.
Started a practically a wide
unrest and social movement
and political movement
across the United States
and I would say across
the nation divisions
and geographic divisions.
All calling for justice
not only for George,
justice for the minorities,
the disadvantaged, the underprivileged.
And I think there's an important lesson
for all of us.
This was 2020.
I'm going to take you 10 years back
to Ben Arous on 17 December, 2010.
Again place and time.
Ben Arous is in Tunisia
and the person is Bouazizi.
Mohamed Bouazizi was
26-years-old when he again
fell a victim to police brutality.
He was unemployed,
trying to work what was considered
illegally on the street,
and in reaction he set himself on fire.
His mom refers to this as an
act to defend his dignity.
That incident started
what everybody talks about
as the Arab uprising.
That code for dignity, for
freedom, for liberation,
for a new world actually
swept the Arab world
and many many many countries
and capitals actually.
So thousands and thousand
and millions of people
taking to the street
demanding minimum
acceptable living conditions
and minimum dignity.
I'll take you 10 years back
and again younger individual.
Take you to Gaza on the
30th of September 2000.
And the person in this
story is Muhammad al-Durrah.
Muhammad was 12-years-old when
he was caught with his father
in a cross fire between
Palestine and the Israeli's
and he was shot by
Israeli soldiers and ended
and his father was wounded.
This took place around the
practically within every day
or two of the start of the
second intifada in Palestine.
And that extended over
more than four years.
The pictures I chose here
I chose intentionally
to show you that this is a
struggle between civilians,
against young and old,
against one of the mightiest
military powers in the
region if not in the globe.
I can't breathe.
I would like to adopt that as a road map
for global public health.
I can't breathe
represents people who are
fighting racism and feeling
that there's structural and systemic
discrimination against them.
I can't breathe is a scream
by people in our region
and most in many many
countries around the world
fighting against authoritarian
system, against corruption.
And I can't breathe part is the voice
of people who are still under occupation
and colonian powers and under three cases
what global public health can do
is actually be part of this struggle
of this passage of this
journey from racism
to a society
or to a world where people's identity
and self-realization is respected.
To a world that moves
from authoritarianism
to perhaps countries where
people are held accountable for,
especially politicians,
for their misdoings,
where they can live in dignity
and express themselves.
Again a passage, a
journey helping people go
from being under occupation
to a world with liberty and freedom.
If you think about this
this is exactly what
we do in public health.
In public health we talk about
community based movements,
we talk about solidarity,
we talk about action,
we talk about listening to the victims,
we talk about listening to
our social participants.
This is what I am calling for here
is to listen to people
saying I can't breathe.
I'm trying to work together with them
to a better future.
I think this sentence summarizes it all
and this is from the landmark report
of the Commission on Social
Determinants in 2008.
That after all,
social injustice is the
main killer in our globe,
it's a killer on a grand scale.
I take all of this to
sort of put it together
in a model of how I myself
look at public health
and global public health.
And I see here three
determinant that actually.
- [Man] That's crazy.
- Influence what we do.
One is identity, how we as individuals,
as human beings, how do we see ourselves?
How do we recognize our
identity and what we stand for?
But at the same time
this could be in contrast
and in conflict with how others see us.
The identity perceived by us
and perceived by the other,
that kind of conflict
determines the health of people
and priorities of people.
Social determinants of health
is known to all of if not most of us.
It's about the occupation and finding,
it's about finding employment,
it's about education,
about these opportunities for better life.
And but I put political
determinants of health
as an independent domain.
And I put it on purpose there.
Because some people claim
and say that it is inclusive,
it is included under social determinants.
I think we need to split it out,
we need to have it out there in our face
because when you talk about
political determinants of health
we're talking about governance,
accountability, corruption,
colonialism, structural violence,
this is what comes to our mind
when we talk about the term
political determinants of health.
And it shouldn't be diluted by any way
by just mixing it up with the other term
of social determinants of health.
And those three impact our health
not only at the personal level
also at the collective
and population level.
The Association of
Schools of Public Health,
schools and programs of
public health here in the U.S.
in 2020 held a leadership retreat.
This is an annual event, it was virtual.
The focus was on structural
and systemic racism.
Of course this was driven
by George Floyd case.
And one of the most
profound statements I heard
at the end of this panel,
when the moderator asked
the deans and directors
what is one thing that you would do
in your school or program
addressing racism?
And dean Thomas LaVeist,
the dean of the Tulane
School of Public Health
said we need to teach our
public health students
the history of the
United States of America.
For me this was a revelation.
It's thought again
speaks to many of the issues that we face
not only in our region, across the world,
that there's history
and there's a background
and there's a context for
everything that we're living in.
And he has this movement that is a book
that is a documentary that speeches
that he refers to as the skin you are in,
the skin you are in defines you.
And I think this is again
an amazing statement,
because he didn't talk
about the color of the skin.
The skin you're in,
because what's inside that
skin is a human being.
And that goes anatomy and
pathology and physiology
and perhaps genetics are
more or less the same.
What differs is that tiny thin envelope
that covers our human being-ness.
And I think that's the
kind of public health
that we should be talking about.
Crossing that barrier,
crossing that skin, to look
at in depth at our humanity
and the human beings.
To add to these concepts
that I am introducing
I would like to introduce the
concept of wounds or traumas.
And there are three
definitions or terms
that I'll use with this.
One, the invisible wound.
We used to talk about the visible wound,
what we can see, what
the physician can stitch.
But we are talking about invisible wounds
that we cannot see that are pushed inside.
And our job as public health people,
our job as public health professionals
is to uncover the wounds inside,
these are the wounds that are caused
by discrimination, by injustice.
They don't show out.
These wounds could
become intergenerational.
There are now reports and
studies talking about slavery
and that it impacts
even our genetic makeup.
These wounds are transferred,
and pains and sufferings are transferred
from one generation to the other
and we need to keep that in mind.
And then the value of wounds.
It's not stable.
We all know the narrative.
We could know and draw the narrative
and how a wound was caused.
Who killed who shot who,
and who was belligerent,
and who was the victim.
But the value of the wound
and how you would perceive it
is defined politically.
Veterans in this country
of the Vietnam War
have been treated differently
than the veterans of the
Gulf War in the same country.
And that's defined politically
with the political agenda
and the mood of the country.
And these values and
how we see these wounds
internal and external differ with time.
To the left of the slide there is a key.
And I think this is a key
that helps us understand
what these wounds are,
but also this key is a symbol.
And maybe I can't talk about it at the end
or under Q and A.
It is also a political symbol.
Now I take you to Lebanon.
And in my presentation I'm
going to zoom in and out
and take you through this journey
using this concept that I
presented as my guideline.
In Beirut August four
2020 six or seven PM,
a time that nobody will forget,
this explosion took place.
This explosion now we have
the time, we have the place,
but this time it was not a person,
this time it was a population,
it was a whole collective experience.
It destroyed a sizable
portion of the City of Beirut.
It killed more than 200 people.
It destroyed tens of thousands of houses,
some of them severely damaged.
It destroyed hospitals
and health care centers.
Three of these hospitals
were severely damaged.
More than 6,000 injuries were reported.
They stormed and the emergency departments
across the hospitals in
Beirut and surrounding
towns and cities.
Not only on their own,
they came with friends,
they came with relatives,
they came with their life, loved ones.
Tens of thousands of people
were actually roaming
around the emergency rooms
and around hospitals
and the City of Beirut
around that time.
We were all worried about
COVID-19 transmission.
There was no way to impose
any protective measure there.
Low and behold this is August four here
and within weeks the
cases of COVID spread out.
If this is a lesson of
how politics and conflict
connect with health
I think this is one of
the striking examples.
People would ask what's in that plume
and what kind of toxic
agents we were exposed to.
But in Lebanon at that time
not only people in Beirut,
I think the strongest and
most common phrase used
was I can't breathe.
In Arabic (Iman speaks
Arabic), I am suffocating.
People across the city
and across the country
were talking about suffocation
and ability to breathe
because of the smoke, because of the dust
that was associated with the destruction.
But also because of this
feeling of total oppression,
of feeling that this political system,
this situation has robbed us
of what has been left of our dignity.
And again.
It connects to all
these individual stories
that I shared at the beginning.
This is again a picture
where you can easily see the damage
and you can easily
observe the external, the visible wounds.
The invisible wounds here
within this lady and others
are things that we need to
keep observing and monitoring
and this is what matters.
Because when you treat the visible wound
people are forgotten.
We need to keep remembering
that these wounds run deep,
run deep to impact people's feelings
and people's mental health.
One study that was done
at the American University Medical Center
and our faculty jointly looked
at mental health disorders
among children less than 18-years-old.
And again anxiety was on the
rise, PTSD, and depression.
Another colleague from our faculty
looked at injuries and has
started now a cohort of injuries.
I'm working with a group across Lebanon
to try and understand the interaction
between intermittent exposure,
health outcomes, and vulnerability.
Just to let you know, none
of these things were funded.
The first two studies
were done with no funds,
totally on voluntary basis.
We've been reaching out to
fund our third proposed study
for more than a year.
There's no money to
document what has happened
and this would be a missed opportunity,
not only for Lebanon, for
the whole world to learn
what can a blast like this,
what can explosion like
this cause do to people
not only on the visible but
also on the invisible wounds.
Just to share with you the context,
this blast was not an incident.
It's not an accident.
This blast is contextualized,
it's part of a stream of
things that were happening
in the country.
We published a paper right after,
talking about the Beirut blast
and the escalation of the crisis.
At the heart of all of this
is a confessional
sectarian political system.
At the heart of all of this
is political and economic mismanagement.
And when the two things exist together
like a country in Lebanon,
you have the worst combination ever.
In a region that is afflicted
by instability and wars.
The turning point, the history is long,
but a turning point was February 14th 2005
when former Prime Minister
Rafic Hariri was assassinated.
That split the country.
And within less than a month
we started talking about in the country
referring to two political
coalitions on blocks in 2005,
the march eight and the march 14.
One with an orientation towards the east
and one with orientation towards the west.
And that kind of polarization
impacted how the country
is being run and lead
to further deterioration
in the management even
of the basic services
provided to the citizens or
the residents of the country.
We actually witness one of the scandalous
unacceptable and unbelievable
garbage crisis that any country could see.
In 2015 the country was drowning
in its garbage.
What you see here is this river,
this river is of white
plastic bags with garbage.
And that's what you see at the shores
and some of the towns and villages.
That was another indicator
of a failing of the governing system,
a failing of a political system,
the failing practically of a state.
Electricity was started experiencing
even further electricity shortages
and more frequent outages.
This is why the way the headquarters
for the electricity of Lebanon.
And it tells you sort of is an indicator
for how bad the situation is.
And think public health,
think health outcome.
No electricity means
your medical equipment
are not running and you
have to look for alternative
sources of power.
This means that your
food cannot be stored,
this means that if it is the bad weather
you might succumb to the weather elements.
And people reverted to alternatives.
And these neighborhood
diesel generators marched
in all over the country.
With that came earth pollution
and the fact that people
and a study was run by
colleagues at the university.
What it showed what
when you turned them off
and you turn them on,
practically the particulate
matters and other toxins
sort of go through the roof.
This lead to social movements.
These social movements were
social slash environmental,
slash political, because they
followed the garbage crisis.
And there were demands,
part of it technical,
part of it social reform,
and part of it political reform.
And this is where
health, politics, social
issues actually come together.
And it's very difficult in many cases
to separate them from each other.
There was a hope there
that perhaps the social
these social movements
political movements, fresh young
people perhaps could impact
the election the
parliamentary election 2018.
It didn't happen.
It didn't happen because again
this is sort of a quick context,
because the whole electric door
is based on sectarian divisions.
So this is the District of Beirut
one and we have eight seats.
Three are reserved to
an Armenian Orthodox.
One is reserved to an Armenian Catholic,
one for a Modernite, one for a Catholic,
one for an Orthodox,
and one for a minority.
You go to Beirut two,
you have six for Sunni, two
for Shia's, one for Druze,
and so on so forth in every
single district in the country.
What does that mean?
That if you are a non
sectarian, if you are secular,
regardless of what geology you carry,
if you want to change the system
you are forced whether
you run for election
or you vote on the election
that your voice counts
and you have to follow
the sectarian divisions,
acknowledge the sectarian
division in the country.
Things got started getting worse and worse
on October 17.
One of the them came up
with an unpopular decision
and for a reason that no one understands
tens and hundreds and thousands of people
took to the street.
Within days there was an uprising,
people refer to it as October
17 revolution in 2019.
People all over the country,
every city, every town,
every village, went down
there and said it has to stop,
things have to stop.
People should be held accountable
and things need to change.
There was an amazing actually
expression of solidarity
when the Lebanese and others joined hands
from the North of Lebanon
to the South of Lebanon
it was a human chain of
tens of thousands of people.
It was interrupted in some places.
Even that interruption the human chain
had a political connotation
and political explanation.
It was peaceful but people were angry
and demanding accountability
and of course the response was brutal
and they were attacked and
taken to prison and injured.
Around the time that
October 17 uprising started
the banks closed its
doors for two three weeks.
And when they opened all of us,
Lebanese, non Lebanese,
anyone who has an account in the bank
we had no access to all our
money, the door was closed.
From there on the banks gave us a stipend.
They would decide on how much money
we can take from our saving account
or our current account in Lebanese lira's,
in dollars, or whatever other currency.
This started the Lebanese pound,
Lebanese currency collapsed.
For 30 years it had it was
pegged at 1,500 lira's,
the dollar, and quickly
over the last three years
you see it's currently I think today
it's close to 30,000 lira's per dollar.
What does this mean?
Just to give you an illustration.
So if your monthly salary
was 1,500,000 lira's
at the end of 2019 that
was 1,000 dollars sadly.
Acceptably, decent, not great but decent.
Now this same salary is 60 dollars.
On top of it you have
no access to your money
if you have any in the banks,
which means that the purchasing power
of the Lebanese totally collapsed,
lost more than 90 to 95% of its value.
High inflation in the country
and lot of frustration on top of that.
People depend on emergencies,
their loved ones outside
Lebanon sending some dollars,
and of course humanitarian
and financial aid
from agencies, international and national.
And then COVID-19
in February 2020.
I'm not going talk about COVID-19
and I'm not going to talk
about the response to COVID-19.
I'm just going to say
that COVID-19 came here
and what it did politically
it stopped all profit in the street.
Everybody went home.
There was lockdown, people went home,
and every single expression
of protest were angered
went away because people
were worried about their
health, their loved ones,
and they were taking this pandemic
as they should, very seriously.
The European report
summarizes all in this quote.
"Decades of political and
financial mismanagement
"combined with COVID-19
and the August 2020
"Port of Beirut explosion
"have brought the country to its knees."
There were bank stipulates
that the Lebanese crisis
it could be possibly among the top three
most severe crisis episodes globally
since the mid nineteenth century.
This is a record for the country.
This situation again according
to this European report,
poverty struck across the
population, 74% of population.
And a sort of poverty considered
under the line of poverty.
Syrian refugees, 90% in extreme poverty.
Most people receive two
hours of electricity per day.
The healthcare sector
is at breaking point.
There's an exodus of health professionals,
nurses, physicians, name it, and others.
And there's a shortage of
medicine and medical supplies.
There's an issue, a very
basic economic issue.
What can you use to charge
people and to buy supplies?
They are two different currencies
that now don't talk to each other
and that are not controlled.
And to top it all
they expect that the economy
will further shrink in 2022.
Again another addition
with the Ukraine war
we all, I didn't know,
but I didn't know that close
to 80% of the wheat in Lebanon
is actually imported from Ukraine.
So this adds also to the challenge
of even putting bread on the table.
Of course I did not forget the
refugees because the refugees
are another dimension within the country
that we need to address.
In Lebanon there is more than
one million Syrian refugees
that started coming influx-ing
and coming to Lebanon
as the war in Syria started in 2011.
And on top of that we talk
about close to 300,000
Palestinian refugees with us for decades.
This.
Report from Brookings talk
about the Syrian refugees
being a crisis within a crisis.
I would say this is a
crisis on top of a crisis,
a crisis interacting with a crisis.
And Syrian's, most of them
have no legal residency,
they're 50% suffer from
insecurity food insecurity
that doubled since 2019.
90% live in extreme poverty,
almost double since 2019.
Situation is not much
different for the Lebanese.
And the country also,
this is a point that
I will refer to later,
the country also when you
look at the healthcare systems
there are multiple healthcare systems
that address the needs
of different populations.
UNHCR, these were the refugees.
UNRWA these were the Palestinian's.
And then with Lebanese,
depending whether you have
private insurance or not,
is the Ministry of Health
or Social Insurance
that takes care of you.
But we don't live in isolation,
we're part of a region,
and we need to understand
a little bit more
how the region is impacting
us and impacting itself.
This is the Arab world that we define
as 22 states that are numbers
of the league of Arab states.
It's not a homogenous region.
It's quite heterogeneous, a
lot of inequities actually.
It comprises some of the
wealthiest countries in the world
and also some of the poorest
countries in the world.
I'm going to focus on two issues
that define the region big time.
One of them is conflicts.
Close to 50% of the Arab
countries are in some kind of
some sort of phase of
political instability
or an upend war and conflict.
What has changed?
There were wars before
the Palestinian issue
has been with us for more than 80 years.
We had the civil war in Lebanon '75,
1975 to 1990.
There was the Iraq War,
the Gulf one, Gulf two,
and so you had these wars here and there,
what has changed now in the region
that you have these multiple
and concurrent conflicts
at the same time?
They are protracted,
they're no more quick wars.
And I would say that the
situation now in the region
and also globally with these conflicts,
that this idea previous idea
that there's a pre conflict
phase, during conflict phase,
and after conflict phase I think is that.
That's the end of it, we
should declare this dead.
You can no more divide conflicts
into these three phases.
They are mingled together.
Even if a war stops the
conflict doesn't stop.
And the fact that they are
concurrent and multiple
they're speaking to each other.
What's pre is post for others.
And again the high number of IDP's,
internal displaced people and refugees,
the highest in the world.
National borders are being
broken down within the country
and across the region.
Anda again these wars are no
more national and local wars,
they are regionalized and
they are internationalized.
One thing that was striking in these wars
that are happening now in the region
and unfortunately across other conflicts
is the weapon-ization of health,
using health as the tool of war.
It happened strikingly in Syria.
The Syrian government and
its allies were clearly
attacking hospitals
and healthcare workers.
And this is happening in Yemen,
so the Arabia attacking
healthcare centers.
It happened in Afghanistan,
even the U.S. has attacked health centers
whether they claim it was
not on purpose or not,
the fact that healthcare facilities
are becoming a target
and now we're seeing it also in Ukraine.
This is what I was talking about
about these huge numbers of population
that are shifting within these
countries, breaking borders.
You have Syrian's in Turkey
more than three million,
you have Syrian's in Lebanon,
more than one million.
You have six million Syrian's
that have been shifted,
displaced, within the country itself.
Jordan, name it, there's
the conceptualization
of a national border for a
conflict is disappearing.
Our colleague Almara Diwachi
and his co-authors and colleagues
have introduced this concept
that referred to as
therapeutic geographies
which they define as the
reorganization of healthcare
within and across borders
because of these conditions.
A Syrian refugee in Turkey
is receiving a totally different care
than a Syrian refugee in
Jordan or Iraq or Lebanon
or if they've gone to Europe.
And within the same country
they could be receiving
also a different care.
You can no more talk about
national healthcare system
and consistent health system.
My dear friend and colleague Fouad Fouad
talks about these dichotomy's
that we need to start thinking about.
The conflict phase
versus the post conflict.
Are we dealing with emergencies
or should we think long-term?
Are we dealing
with acute illnesses and
health problems or chronic?
Remember these refugees
are mostly from middle income countries.
We're talking cancer, chronic
diabetes, heart disease,
we're talking injuries.
We're not talking about diarrhea,
and sanitation wholly.
We're healthcare systems, we
need to address this issue.
Are we running parallel
healthcare systems?
How can these systems talk
to each other and integrate?
Are we do we limit our
work to humanitarian
and then think of development later,
or should they converse with
each other at this point?
And again who is our target,
who is our population?
Is it refugees?
Citizens?
Who takes priority and
who deals with whom?
These are really very striking dichotomy's
that define not only the health outcomes,
also the health system and the priorities.
El Norte.
People are moving where?
Migrants, whether because
of environmental migration
or conflict Saharan Africa, North Africa,
all our region, everybody is moving north
for more stability and for the
hope for a better life
and more stable life.
The other issue in the Arab world besides.
The.
Conflicts is the issue of
ecological sustainability
which is actually threatening
the survival of the region.
I'm not going to spend time here
but I am going to share numbers.
If our population today in the Arab world
is going to double or
increase by 50% if not double
from 350 people are seeing
to 500 or 600 million
in 50 years.
And if most of this
shift is in urbanization
and larger and larger epicenters.
And if this region is the most stressed.
You see the red here,
this region is the most
stressed in water availability.
And it's expected if all these scenarios
for climate change are correct
that we'll be he first region
to run out of fresh water.
And if this continues that we are
the largest importers
of cereal in the world
Because we have added and semi arid lands.
You put all of these together
and you could really see what could happen
in the region in 20,
30, 40 or 50 years time.
And if these predictions and
projections with climb change
then our region will be
the hottest in the globe
and the least inhabitable in the globe.
You're talking about
migrations in this case
environmental on top of
conflict and economic.
And you can size it up in your mind.
The DPM of WHO EMRO speaks
about the challenges
to actually achieve
SDG's, weak governance,
fragmented healthcare, limited data,
the emergencies and the conflicts,
and of course disparities in equalities.
I'm going to throw in
a piece of history here
for the region.
And of course this is
a personal perspective.
I think of three dates that
are extremely important.
1918.
This is when World War one ended
and there was lot of
aspiration in the Arab region,
especially in the Levant,
sort of the near Middle East,
the western Middle East.
And there was a hope of an
Arab kingdom of independence
of self-governance, but again it turns out
that the British and the French empire
decided to split that region,
create nation states that
were put under mandate,
a nicer word for
colonialism, for 30 years.
1938 is another important date,
and that's the time and the year
when oil was discovered in Saudi Arabia.
That transform the region
into becoming a very sensitive
and important geopolitical area.
And it clings to the whole question
of energy and sources of energy.
And of course 1948.
Because in 1948 again if you
look at it that year presents
the birth of a new state in
the region the State of Israel
versus the fact that for the Palestinian's
and the Arab world it is referred to
as the catastrophe and (Iman
speaks foreign language).
It is the time when hundreds
of thousands of Palestinian's
were uprooted and forced out.
And that still defines our relationships,
still defines the politics,
still even defines
these what we refer to
as regional coalitions.
And orientation.
For those who still think
that I'm over claiming things
this line here in the Arab world
to the north of this line you find Iran,
Iraq, Syria, and Lebanon.
This is one axis.
This is an axis that is looking east.
Now in Lebanon there is a division,
and maybe that's where
some of the problems are.
And to the south of this
line you have Saudi Arabia,
Jordan, Egypt, that are looking west.
You'll find that most
of these countries now
are starting negotiating
and a cause with Israel.
And again it does define
the politics and the social structure
and stability or
instability in the region.
This is Turkey again
interfering in Syria and Libia.
And this is sort of the
regional-ization of the nation.
This blue arrow here
is the Nile River.
And this Nile River again
linking to water scarcity
and link it to climate change,
we know that what's happening now
with Egypt, Sudan, and Ethiopia
and the dam in Ethiopia,
this is a recipe for future conflict
whether we like it or not.
And again this is where
climate change, migration,
conflict, politics, come together.
And then shouldn't be surprised
why the Arab world is the spends more
on military than health.
It's the only such region
in the whole world.
Moving out to the globe.
We're talking now about 84 million
forcibly displaced people,
I'm sorry about that,
this was November 2021.
Because now we're talking
about an extra seven million Ukrainian's
that have been added to this statistic.
And this number keeps
increasing year after year.
That tells you that there
is a crisis in humanity
and there is a crisis in our world.
And it's not necessarily limited
to one region or the other.
Some of the victims of
the sometimes forgot
are the young, the children and the youth,
what we refer to as the lost generation.
And you can also build
up with your imagination,
what does it mean when you
have your full generation
that lost whole, that was displaced,
didn't go to school, starved?
What kind of future they have
and how can they rebuild their countries?
Coming at the end to hope.
I have ideas here
but because of time I'm going to stop here
but share only one slide
and say I see a lot of hope
in the young generation.
We have handed over to
the young generation
a world in a total mess.
And we are counting on this new generation
perhaps to do a better
job than our generation.
And perhaps.
Try to introduce real change.
We have ideas for hope and change
at the level of the community
and civil movements.
The academic institutions have a role
and definitely there's important direction
that we should take and
that's global solidarity.
With that I think our hopes winning.
It's still in our hands
but we call the shots.
I don't want to take more time
to leave time for questions
and some interaction.
Thank you.
- Doctor Iman thank you so much
for this unbelievable presentation.
It made me very emotional I must say.
Thank you for that final
slide, the hope slide,
because it again it
really made me emotional
and also reminded me why many of us
got interested in public health.
And as you made these
this amazing presentation
it's really making me think
about how can we prepare our students,
the next kind of the future
leaders in public health
to be far better prepared than we are
in responding to armed conflict,
to preventing these
political determinants of it?
Because frankly you were bringing up
the importance of
history of public health,
which I completely agree,
values of public health.
Honestly I don't think we
are spending enough time
addressing those issues in our curriculum.
So I'm just thinking, has the
American University of Beirut
faculty health sciences,
have they redesigned their
public health curriculum
to better prepare
the next generation of
students to understand?
Because armed conflict
is kind of a new thing
for many public health
schools in the United States.
I must say only a handful of them
have some sort of a
structured program for it.
It's kind of seen as outside
of the scope of public health.
So how do we train
the next generation of
public health leaders
to be far better prepared than we are
in responding to armed conflict?
That's just some question
that came to my mind.
And by the way I wanna ask the audience
to ask put their questions in chat box.
- Yeah.
So Kaveh you ask a very important question
but I don't want to limit it
only to conflicts and wars.
I think one of the issues
that is at the heart of public
health education and training
institutionally and at
the level of individuals
is the whole concept of injustice.
And I don't think we do
the job that would expect it to do there.
We wait for incidents to
happen and we react to them.
We have to be proactive
and start thinking about
what I'm not recommending
that we only discuss politics in classes.
We need to discuss (Iman
mumbles), statistics,
and by the month issues
every single core discipline
within public health.
But the students, the faculty,
the institutions when they work together,
they need to understand the context.
What we did at the faculty,
we took a bold step actually
in our vision we introduced
that we're a school that
is thriving or working
or would like to be leaders,
pushing for peace, justice,
equity, and health.
We've actually put peace,
justice, and equity before health.
And this is out of commitment.
It doesn't mean that we're able to do it,
but I think schools of
public health need to realize
that we need to address the core problem
and start working and we need
to learn from each other.
You need to instill values
and sensitivity within the students
in addition to the skills that they need.
And also we need to build institutions.
And that's a role for
a university like Yale,
for the school like Yale
School of Public Health
and other schools here
that when they think
about building capacity
it's not only about building the capacity
of individual researchers here and there.
Building the capacity of institutions
because people leave.
I might be in (Iman mumbles)
I might be in Lebanon,
I might leave Lebanon,
or some one of my colleagues
might live in Lebanon.
The university stays
and the investment should be
at the institutional level
not at only the individual level.
We've introduced a certificate
and several courses
on conflict within our MPH program.
- Thank you.
Opening up for questions
from the audience.
Let me just see the chat box.
There is a question I see,
what kind of partnerships
that can help Lebanon
deal with the concurrent
health crisis particularly a partnership
between academic institutes
and other agencies in Lebanon?
- Okay.
I'm not to be here different level.
Some of them is very primitive.
Primitive like the Maslow's
hierarchy of needs,
that's sort of the bottom one down there.
I was talking to dean Vermund
to stand a few days ago.
And they said my visit here to Yale
to spend a few months here
gave me a breathing space,
give me at least I have
electricity around me,
I have internet, I have hot water,
I don't have to worry about that
every single minute of the day.
And I can think.
I can talk to other people.
Even at that level, please
do not over complicate it.
Even at that level of
academics, scholars, researchers
can come over, spend weeks
or month and go back.
I'm not talking about
scholars at risk staying here,
I'm talking about people who come,
take a breather, and return.
I'm talking about exchange of
faculty, exchange of students.
Thinking about research
that we can do together.
There's a lot that we can learn
from our partners in the global north
but there's a lot that our
partners in the global north
can learn from us.
How do we deal with these problems?
They're not in any textbook frankly,
they're not in any textbook,
this is not what we teach our students.
The textbook is being written
and we need to work on that.
And I think this is one of the some
of the questions and dichotomy's
that our friend Fouad Fouad has posed
could be actually at the heart
of some of this work
that we can do together.
- Sorry.
I see a bunch of questions.
What's your advice for
understanding and comprehending
the complex and multifaceted
history of countries that improve
public health professionals ability
to be sensitive and enable themselves
to adequately address the
challenges of these countries?
- I'm not sure I got the question fully.
- Let me ask.
I see Michael, Mike Bay,
do you wanna ask your questions?
I see your hand, raise your hand.
- Thank you doctor Nuwayhid.
Really it's very I think
it's the perfect present.
I wanted to say thank you doctor Nuwayhid
for a phenomenal presentation
that really sums up
decades of inefficiency,
a lot of problems in the region
that kind of mostly get summarized
by in Lebanon specifically
a country where people did not
have to face any dictatorship
really had the chance to go and vote.
And they voted for the
same people left or right
who kind of had opposing political views,
but for 40 years did not provide
any sense of accountability.
A system that was based on clientelism
where people who wanted to go and get
a surgery but they could not afford
they would go to the politician
who would go and pay for that procedure.
If they wanted access to clean water
or a healthy and a good
environment to live in,
the clientelism of the politicians
was the thing that they should.
And you would only see that
every four to six years
whenever elections would happen.
The other comment I wanted to talk about
was about the healthcare
education in Lebanon.
The issue is that we do have a lot
of public health education in Lebanon
in universities such as AUB,
but we do not have a focus or emphasis
on healthcare management and
healthcare administration
which does not I think in my opinion
equip the young Lebanese generation
with the principles to create
sustainable innovations.
Because all what I see is a lot of times
organizations and GO's come into Lebanon,
they do a project, they
patch a certain situation,
but who are not having a reform
and a system that is already
broken on so many levels.
So I feel like if we need to make change
it has to be a big reform
rather just patching or covering holes
in the meantime.
But thank you so much doctor Nuwayhid,
that was an amazing presentation.
- Yeah Michael it's
not that we don't have,
we have several programs,
maybe we need more.
And at our university
we have an MPH program
with concentration on health
management and policy,
we have an executive master
in healthcare leadership.
Similarly with several other
universities in the country.
Do we need more?
Yes.
But again I would like
to see these programs
contextualize and move from the technical
of healthcare management
to looking at issues that
like the issues I've described
a while ago of how to deal
with these dichotomy's
and these complexities.
And we have an opportunity
to look at our condition.
And I am sorry to use the term, as a lab,
as an experimental lab
to actually examine that
and report on it and test it.
And with total transparency over there.
- Thank you.
- I apologize we are running
out of time.
Because I know doctor Iman has
another meeting right after.
But Leah why don't you
ask the last question.
- Thank you so much doctor Iman Nuwayhid.
I am an actually an AUB alumni myself,
I just graduated from their
medical school last year
and I came to the Yale
School of Public Health
to pursue a master in
healthcare management.
Thank you so much for your presentation.
My question to you
is you mentioned the political
determinants of health.
And in a country like Lebanon
where a lot of the political
influence is foreign,
how can you take a proactive
approach to public health
within that political
determinants of health sphere
when so much of it is out of your hands?
It's just the government
that's either east or west,
like you said there's no continuity there.
So I was just wondering
what's a proactive approach
to that in your opinion?
- Definitely.
One I used to present to the
board of trustees at the UBN
to many conferences I used to say
we are an activist
school of public health.
And I don't think we
should be ashamed of that.
We need to start looking at these cases.
They are.
And not necessarily with set answers,
but we need to start
examining these issues.
We're not.
So you're right, you're right
that you have this general feeling
that it's out of our hands.
We have the most corrupt
perhaps political system ever.
It's sectarian, what can you do?
I think what we can do is continue to work
in spite of these obstacles.
Continue dreaming of a better
society and of a better country.
For you as a physician
look beyond the clinical,
look beyond the disease to
try to look at this wider
disease that we're all
suffering from which is social injustice.
I think these are the concepts
that we need to start introducing.
We haven't done enough and
that's why you're right,
maybe we're not ready.
We don't know how to deal with it.
But I think we need to challenge ourselves
and commit to that to start
looking there different.
And this is not about Lebanon.
I think it's the U.S. as much as Europe
as much as Africa, as
much as the Middle East,
as much as Asia.
We all need to do that.
I see a note here from a different
saying we need to address the
politics of public health.
True.
We need to not to be shy
to shy away from talking politics.
Not engaging in the politics necessarily
but talking politics and making sure
that there is a political
context and dimension
to public health.
It's not a technical field.
Politic, health is not a technical issue.
Health is a political
issue, is a social issue,
and it's determined by
the conditions we live in,
we work in, by all these
different structures
that determine our lives and our futures
and the future of our children.
- Last question from Feha.
- Thank you so much for the presentation.
My name is Feha from Sudan.
It's actually a comment
more than a question.
I just wanted to say at this point,
first thank you for presenting this
because I didn't know
the situation in Lebanon
and it's so much replicated
at many of in the
countries in the regions.
One of the thing that we are
start talking about in Sudan
that now we need to work
outside the health field
to tackle the issues of health.
So we start talk about now
we need to politicize health,
to make sure the politician nowaday
consider health as part of their agenda
which is not really happening.
Because when the
political decision happens
and the health have been impacted
there is no actual action happen
in term of what can we do and so on.
So thank you very much
for this presentation
and we are looking forward
for more discussion in this actual.
- And I look forward to hearing you
talking about Sudan again
in the context of Africa
and the Arab world.
'Cause your situation is as
complex if not more than ours.
Good luck to you.
- Thank you for all the participant,
thank you so much doctor Iman.
We should've made this
much longer (Kaveh laughs)
than an hour because there's
lots of lots of interest
in conversation with you.
But hopefully we will have
another talk with doctor Iman.
Thank you so much, really appreciate it.
- Thank you all.
Appreciate that.